الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان بعد ان
سمحت لهم السلطات او قوات الامن بالدخول
الى المجمع الرئاسي بداوا يتوافدون الى
المجمع الرئاسي هنا في العاصمه التركيه
انقره المجمع الرئاسي حيث سيلقي الرئيس
خطاب الشرفه وكما تشاهدون البوابه
الرئيسيه لهذا الميدان الذي سيدخل منه
الانصار الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان يتدفقون
الى هذه البوابه وقد تم يعني
علق او تم تعليق او انزال العلم التركي
وايضا صور صوره للرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان
وايضا على الجانب الاخر صوره لمؤسس
الجمهوريه التركيه مصطفى كمال اتاتورك اذن
خطاب الشرطه سيكون هنا في العاصمه التركيه
ومن هذا المكان الذي نتواجد فيه الان بعد
تقريبا اعلان النتائج النهائيه من قبل
الهيئه العليا الانتخابات لمتابعه المزيد
ما هو البرامج وال
قصصريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على
اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات